صباح النور يعني ورقه قاعد اشوف الصور
حسيت انه ساللوا عابي ابي ابي اجرب هذه
الاطباق خليني اسالك قبل لنبدا باي شيء ما
هو اغرب طعم ذقته وتركيبه عجيبا صدمت من
طعمها لم تتوقعها
هلا والله في كتير قصص بس اهم شيء يعني
اكتر شغلات لما نحن كعرب ما بنعرفها هو
مثلا الهورس ريدش
في شغلات مثل الوسابي الاساس اللي بتنحط
معود هاي كلياتها قصص نحن مالنا متعودين
عليها فلما اول مره عرفت لمحمد طبعا
نزلناها بكثير امور طبعا طبعا طيب خلينا
خلينا لازم تطلع بيكون
خلينا نفهم اكثر ونشوف كمان واحنا يعني
نتحدث وانت عم تشتغل شيف محمد بدنا نعرف
كيف اطباق عربيه قدرت انك تنقلها للعالميه
مع انه المكونات
والروح مختلفه تماما
[تصفيق]
اكثر من شوربه
لا بتصير شوفي هاي صارت شوربه
الله
فانا
الطريقه اللي بفكر فيها انه دائما الجيست
لازم يجي وياخذ اكسبيريانس لازم يعرف شو
عم ياكل يتعلم شو عم ياكل ومن هون بقى
بتبنوا كيف بدنا ننقل الاكل العربي لنكست
طيب الشاعر يقول الاذن تعشق قبل العين
احيانا واحنا نقول احيانا العين تاكل قبل
قبل المعده او حتى قبل قبل
الفم اليوم هذه الخلطات والالوان اللي
اللي الشيف محمد يحطها في الطبق على اي
اساس يختارها
[موسيقى]
هلا اول
براونيز مثلا تمام شو اطيب الشي انت بتحبه
مع البراونيز
بتر صح تمام فهلا مثلا المكون الاساسي الي
عم حطوا البينوت هلا البراونيز طيبه هيك
مع شوكليت سائل بس شو بيجي معها طيب بيجي
معك شغلات كرونشي لانه هي بدها تكون هيك
فاتره شوي فمنحط عليها هدول المخدات
الصغيره المحشيه كريمه
تمام تمام فمن هون انتم بتحاولوا الصحن من
كونه شي سمبل شي كتير بسيط لشيء كثير عظيم
كبرزنتيشن كطعمات كمان لانه نحن هون يعني
انا اهم شغله بوجهها من خلال شاشتكم
الكريمه انه لما نحنا بدنا نطور الاكل
العربي ما نلعب بالهويه الاساسيه تبع
الاكل العربي مثلا عم نعمل تبوله معروفه
شو هي خلص يعني معروفه
بقدونس برغل بندوره عصير ليمون وكذا
ما نلعب بالهويه الاساسيه طب انت عم بتقول
ما بتلعب بالهويه الاساسيه ولكن
خصوصيه
لشيء عالمي يستصيره الغرب مثلا
تماما هلا الغرب بس يجون عنا يعني روح
قلبهم انه مثلا يذوق اكلنا العربي فانا
التبوله مثلا
تبوله انا ممكن اساوي بدال الليمون صوص
يعني ساويه رغوه وهيك انا بكون ما لعبت
بالمنتج الاساسي اللي هو اول العنصر
الاساسي بالصلصه
ليمون وزيت زيتون بس زيت الزيتون انا فيني
حوله من كونه الكويت او سائل لحتى اساويه
باودر وبيعطي نفس الطعمه في طبعا بودره
خاصه بتيجي من اسبانيا بتيجي من دول تانيه
بتحول اي الكويت لباودر وهي طبعا مسموحه
وصحيه وما بياثر عليها اسئله انه معقول
بنفس المقادير
احيانا بتختلف
اوف
بده مثلا 100 جرام من البودر فهون
بيتغيروا معنا هون شطاره الشيف كيف ينقل
الاكلات من او خلينا نقول
وممكن تحويل اي سائل
الشيخ محمد شو الطبق المفضل انت لديك من
هاي الخلطه العربيه مع العالم
اكل عربي انا بحب الفريكه كتير
بس كاكل غربي وين ما بروح لازم اكل ستان
اوف
بس اوبشن
طيب وطبعا الفريك الفريكه فيها لحمه
مع جاج مشوي والدجاج يكون
مع شويه لبن بخيار على جنب طبعا يعني شي
من الاخر هلا هون البراونيز خلاص
خلينا نهائي اذا كان بالامكان هاي طبقه
النهائي طبعا انا هون انا معروف بدبي
دائما بحط ايدها بالفلاور
يعطيك الف عافيه وصحه وهنا لمين حياكم
شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات